hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
if you have not been sleeping under a
rock or whatever it is in recent years
and you have
some interest in physics and science
more broadly
you will have heard of quantum computers
you all know about quantum mechanics you
all know about computers
there seems to be a new thing on the
horizon where we're going to use quantum
mechanics to build a new powerful
different kind of computer in fact i
sometimes speak in the future tense it's
happened we have
working quantum computers right now but
so far they're not big enough and
they're not efficient enough they're not
accurate enough to really
beat their classical counterparts at any
particular kind of calculation that you
might want to do
however the technology is improving the
theoretical
understanding is improving we're very
hopeful that
pretty soon quantum computers will be
doing things
more efficiently for certain kinds of
things than classical computers do so
it's a very obvious fun topic for us to
discuss here on mindscape
we've brought in one of the world's top
experts my caltech colleague john
preschool
and john like me started out as a
theoretical particle physicist
cosmologist
gravity person and he made a very
explicit choice to move into
quantum information science and quantum
computing and he's since become
one of the world's leaders in that
project he's also
the best person to talk to about
the big picture for quantum computing
because as we'll discuss
in the podcast in the conversation
though he
is certainly personally extremely
excited
about the both the intellectual
adventure of quantum computing and the
technological prospects for making it
work
he is also relentlessly careful
not to overhype so he's very very
specific about what he thinks
quantum computers will be good for and
especially
the sort of most obvious thing in the
world which is simulating quantum
mechanical systems
like chemical reactions or materials or
something like that
it's less clear that quantum computers
are going to be
very helpful for giant optimization
problems the traveling salesman problem
or something like that but maybe they
will
so we talk about what quantum computers
are what the best technologies are to
make them happen
and the prospects for using them where
they will really be useful
uh what kinds of problems we'll be
addressing with them why people are so
excited about it at the end of the day
probably will not have a quantum
computer in your smartphone but they
probably will be useful for various
things we can't even yet anticipate
it's clear that this is a very exciting
time to be thinking about this stuff i
mean we not
only talk about quantum computers but
how the ideas from quantum information
theory
have radically changed our views of
quantum gravity and black holes and
emergent space time and some of my
favorite topics
along those lines this is also an area
where john is one of the world's leaders
so he's a great person to talk to about
it
i'll mention as i sometimes do that we
have resources out there for
mindscape listeners we have a whole
website preposterousuniverse.com
podcast you can get not only the audio
files obviously for the different
podcast episodes
but we have show notes so there'll be
links to people's web pages and their
twitter bios and things like that
and also we have full transcripts for
every podcast so if you want to
find something there is a search engine
right there if you say well someone was
talking about that on mindscape
we have very very good ways of searching
the entire
mindscape archive for whatever topic for
whatever keywords you want to look for
so check that out
preposterous universe.com podcast and
let's go
john prescott welcome to the mindscape
podcast great to be here sean
so you're someone who did something
interesting i mean you've done many
interesting things but among the
interesting things is
uh you had a good career going as a
pretty straightforward
uh quantum field theory particle
physicist
cosmologist the kind of stuff that i
grew up doing myself and thinking about
and
somewhere you made a not very dramatic
but a noticeable shift into quantum
information and quantum computing so
i guess can i mix up two questions
together first is why
that shift and secondly do you have any
bigger picture thoughts about
shifting one's research focus uh later
in life i mean you're you know
you're at an age when many physicists
are thinking about retiring and in some
sense you're peaking now in terms of
your uh
uh you know contributions to a very
vibrant and active field
that's hard that's just yet to come
that's right exactly
well so the shift you're talking about
occurred about 25 years ago
and you know well you were around then
uh this was the mid-90s
and what happened i think which made me
more receptive to going in a new
direction
was the ssc got cancelled oh yeah you
know for my generation
of particle physicists of it was uh that
was our great hope
right we uh we were a little too later i
was i'm i'm older than you but
i got my phd in 1980. and missed by a
few years the opportunity to
participate in you know solidifying
the core theory the standard model of
particle physics so
so our big hope was what comes after the
standard model the so-called uh
you know beyond the standard model
physics where we thought there were a
lot of big questions that we could
answer
and that was what the ssc was supposed
to do the superconducting super collider
they started digging a tunnel
in texas and spent a couple of billion
dollars and then for
complex political reasons it got
canceled and so i started to ask myself
what now
you know it was we were going to be able
to
do some of that physics eventually yeah
but it was maybe a couple of decades
away
and i think that made me more receptive
to uh
looking into new things now meanwhile
while i was waiting for the ssc
i was thinking about crazy stuff like
how to black holes
right process information and that
was my excuse for digging a little bit
into quantum information and uh
you know i learned about things like
quantum teleportation
and you know quantum cryptography
partly for fun and partly because i
thought
those ideas might be helpful for
understanding
information processing at a more
fundamental level
and then something big happened peter
shaw discovered the factoring algorithm
that was 1994
and that was an eye-opener for many
people including me
you know it made me feel that um
this was a serious business that the
difference between problems we could
solve
with computers um
and the problems we can't solve because
they're too hard you know that
different shifts because this is a
quantum world not a classical one and i
just thought that was a really really
interesting idea
and you know how it is when when you're
in the middle of a transition like that
you don't quite see it happening it
seems a little more adiabatic but over
the course of a couple of years
you know i realized most of the things
that i was excited about and thinking
about had to do with quantum computing
so it sounds like it's a there's a
little bit of everything because i can
imagine these shifts happen
sometimes like you say adiabatically
people just gradually shift sometimes
it's a
intentional reflection on what they're
doing and sometimes there's some
external event that might shift things
and for you is all three at once
yeah of course you know i'm imagine
there's a little bit of
rational reconstruction of what happened
in the
uh description i just gave you it was a
somewhat uh
complicated time because you know i had
students and yeah they were working on
various things and some of them got
excited about quantum computing and some
of them didn't
and uh but you know everybody turned out
all right
well and do you have then any lessons
for uh
this question more generally in academia
even forget about physics i mean we
don't really encourage or
set up or provide pathways for people to
make dramatic career transformations in
the middle of their careers in their 40s
or 50s right i mean
should we or you know is the system
pretty good as it is
it helped that i had tenure yeah you
know i didn't have to worry about that
and so i had that luxury of uh you know
taking uh
a year or so to acquaint myself with
another field it was easier then because
the field was
new and there wasn't as much to learn
but what was really
helpful and you've had this experience
too probably
is i taught a course yeah and you know i
did that for the first time in 1997 and
you know a lot of the stuff was
pretty fresh and i really enjoy
kind of synthesizing materials and try
kind of distilling them to what i think
is important so that was really fun to
do
but it also deepened my understanding
and made me feel like i was
you know kind of on the cutting edge of
the field by the time i finished
teaching that course it was a year-long
course
now another thing that was nice is that
the community was very receptive you
know
it was a small community it's bigger now
but you know you might have
wondered if this interloper coming in
from particle physics who thinks he's
such a big shot
who knows uh starts doing quantum
computing whether there would be any
uh resentment and i didn't encounter
anything like that in fact
uh people were happy it's sort of
validated finally right
you know what they were doing was uh was
interesting
and valuable that i was so fascinated by
it
so it's a great community and you know i
learned a lot from
from people uh at uh conferences and
summer schools those first couple of
years and that was really fun too
so we've already used the words etc but
uh what is a quantum computer i mean
should we
start with what is quantum mechanics do
you have a favorite way of explaining
quantum mechanics or do we just dive
right into
what quantum information is well i'll
tell you what a quantum computer is not
it's not just a computer like the ones
we have now but
much much faster it really processes
information in a very different way
and to sort of jump
past what is quantum mechanics part well
not really i mean
the in quantum mechanics when you have a
lot of particles
the description of how those particles
behave
that quantum mechanics uses has great
extravagance
if i wanted to describe in terms of
ordinary information
classical bits the way we usually
store and process information in
ordinary life
if i wanted to describe what a quantum
system with many particles is
doing the the number of bits i would
need is just you know inconceivably
vast now there's a catch though
which is of course if i want to get
information out of a quantum system i
want
ordinary classical information you know
bits i can write down
or put in my head and to get information
out of a quantum system uh well
you know if you qubits are what we call
the fundamental units the analog
bits you have to measure them and when
you
measure a qubit you just get one bit of
information
so you know if you have a few hundred
qubits
a description of some typical state of a
few hundred cubits in terms of classical
information
would be something you could never write
down because
it involves more bits than the number of
atoms the visible universe
but if you want to get information out
you can't get more than 300 bits out of
300 qubits
so this is the tension in quantum
computing that somehow this extravagant
quantum world which is largely hidden
from us is a resource
if we can figure out how to use it but
it's not a simple thing
because you know we're um
our access to all that rich quantum
information is very limited
and so it turns out we can't use quantum
computing to just speed up any problem
we want to solve
the problem has to have the right
structure and we have to be sufficiently
clever to figure out how to use all that
rich quantum information that's you know
behind the barrier that uh
we only have limited ability to
penetrate
so when you say qubit uh the classical
bit is zero or one
the qubit is in some superposition of
zero or one
probably most mindscape listeners have
heard me say words like that before
and then of course when you have
multiple qubits they're entangled with
each other and
it would seem to be like just one qubit
in principle that there's probably a way
of thinking about
why quantum computers are better which
is entirely wrong which is that
even one qubit has a huge amount of
information right because it
requires a real number or in fact a
complex number to specify where you are
in that qubit land whereas a classical
bit is just zero or one
but that's actually not the important
thing the important thing is the
entanglement between the qubits right
yeah and that's why we seem to be forced
if we want to describe in terms of class
there's sort of a mismatch between
information in the classical world and
in the quantum world because of
entanglement
entanglement of when i have a system
with many particles
which are highly entangled that's the
word we use you know for the
characteristic correlations among
the parts of a quantum system that has
many parts
the correlations among those are just
different from correlations among parts
of a classical system
and they're what's so interesting about
entanglement
from my point of view is that uh there's
no succinct way of describing it
in terms of classical information
and i think that some of the thing one
one aspect here that maybe
the non-experts don't appreciate as much
is that
entanglement really wasn't that big a
deal
for many many decades after we invented
quantum mechanics right i mean einstein
podolski and rosen sort of tried to
emphasize it and we had these puzzles
but
probably you just like me when we took
our quantum mechanics classes
there's a lot of tunneling through
barriers and simple harmonic oscillators
and solving the schrodinger equation
it's entanglement was kind of
there in the background but not
emphasized is that is that an accurate
way of putting it
we didn't learn bell inequalities you
know actually
so i'm saying potolski and bedolsky and
rosen that was 1935
and you know there was a there were some
thoughtful responses
to that paper which talked about how
these correlations and quantum systems
are different from classical ones
uh from schrodinger for example who
understood pretty well what it meant
but not much happened for 30 years and
then bell in the mid 60s
uh came up with this idea of bell
inequalities which
in a very visceral way indicated how
these correlations are different from
the ones we can realize
you know with ordinary information like
we encounter in
in everyday life and so i could have
learned that when i took
quantum mechanics because i took quantum
mechanics in the early 70s and welded
that in the mid 60s
but it was just it wasn't part of the
quantum curriculum i guess it wasn't for
you either
now it happened though something uh and
maybe this also planted a seed
which uh explains the answer to your
first question about how i made this
transition
when i was an undergraduate at princeton
you know we were supposed to do a
research project
when as juniors and who knows how to do
that so you have to go around and knock
on doors and see if anybody has any idea
and somebody uh suggested to me
because i said as undergraduates often
do
oh i'm interested in the interpretation
of quantum theory
to uh one of the professors he said oh
well you should
you should look into uh the epr paradox
which i had never heard of
but it turned out there was a instructor
who had just
arrived at princeton that fall who had
just
done an experiment for his phd with john
clouser that was stuart friedman
freeman and klauser did this experiment
in um you know the early 70s
which was oh well one of the first to
sort
of uh convincingly uh show that these
bell inequalities are violated
in a quantum system and so you know
there really is a difference between
quantum and classical information
and so you know i pumped him a little
bit and i wrote a little paper about
uh epr so i thought about that some and
so that probably also
uh made me more receptive to some of
this quantum information
stuff one 20 years ago i realized it was
pretty interesting
i'm excited to share the news that the
great courses plus
is now one dream one dream is everything
we know and love about the great courses
plus and so much
more wondering provides fantastic video
and audio learning experiences tons of
great content
to enrich our lives with mind-blowing
moments and you can still stream all of
your favorites from the great courses
these include videos that are created in
partnership with national geographic
smithsonian history and more
if you like the topic of today's podcast
for example there's a course by mark
berkson on one dream called
cultural literacy for religion
everything the well-educated person
should know whether you believe or not
religion plays an important part in
human history and you can learn that
right there on wonderium so sign up now
through this special url to get this
great offer a 14-day
free trial of unlimited access go to
wundrium.com mindscape that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash mindscape one dream dot
com
slash mindscape well that's interesting
because
like you say every undergraduate wants
to think about the interpretation of
quantum mechanics and
usually that uh instinct is just beaten
out of them but for you at least it
turned into something
productive uh now years later
i take it that what one stance is about
the interpretation of quantum mechanics
doesn't really enter into your everyday
life as a quantum information theorist
right i mean
uh i talk about the interpretation of
quantum mechanics a lot but let's just
be clear to the audience
the practitioners in the field kind of
don't spend their time worrying about
that is that also accurate
it's less accurate than it used to be i
think okay um at least
in the quantum information community uh
some uh young people i think
are attracted to quantum information
because uh
you know they think it is revealing
uh concerning the foundations of quantum
theory
um even so i i accept your statement
that it's not it's not what uh it's not
our bread and butter
yeah even in quantum information uh
there are other things that we're
usually thinking about unless we're
listening to you or reading one of your
books or something
having said that do you have a favorite
formulation of quantum mechanics at the
fundamental level
i'm an avreadian um
so i think you and i are pretty aligned
actually yeah
um i uh
i'm comfortable with nothing happening
in the world
besides unitary evolution if your
audience knows what i mean by that
that measurement isn't something
fundamentally different
and uh you know what i and people say
well it's you know but
it requires all these worlds and stuff
and you know
so there's another a place where the
word extravagance seems appropriate that
we need to have this very
very rich description of experience
because we include
all the alternatives um
but i guess my question would be then
well suppose it were true how would the
world be different than we actually
experience uh and uh observe it to be
and so i just didn't find it find that
appealing it seems
minimal you know there's nothing
happening but the schrodinger equation
and things are evolving
and if we can reconcile that with uh
what we observe about physics then uh
i think that's uh i mean
if you have for another interpretation
that's fine with me i'm not going to get
dogmatic about it or anything
but i'm pretty happy with that that
sounds good to me i'm not gonna i'm not
let's just declare victory right there
and uh move on to that we've got
something to argue about
yeah exactly um so we have these qubits
they can be superpositions of zero or
one if you measure them you're gonna get
either zero or one or
whatever product whatever actual
physical property you're measuring of
them
and they're entangled so can we just be
a little bit more specific to help the
audience out there visualize
what exactly does that mean that they're
entangled and how does that mean
that there's more oomph to the
computational power
well what it means is that
even if we have a complete description
of the full system of all the
particles and by complete i mean
you know the most complete description
that we think the laws of quantum
mechanics will allow
when we look at part of the system we
can't predict what we're going to see
you know the
we can have a complete description of
the whole thing
but uh still be very uncertain about the
parts
that's what entanglement is so you know
you could imagine like you have a book
and it's 100 pages long and
if it's an ordinary book you can read
the pages one at a time
or you can even give each page to
a different friend and they all read the
pages and they get together and talk
and they can reconstruct everything
that's in the book
but if it's written in qubits and the
pages are highly entangled with one
another
you can look at the pages one at a time
but you just see random gibberish
you don't get any information from it or
essentially none
and that's true even if you look at all
the pages
one at a time you're still missing
almost all the information that's in
that quantum book
there's information there you just can't
read it that way because the information
isn't
printed on the individual pages it's
encoded almost
entirely in how these pages are
correlated with one another
that's the entanglement and describing
those
correlations in terms of ordinary bits
that's what's
so expensive to you know
describe that the way we usually
describe and think about information
is um you know completely unreasonably
costly and so that's sort of the
that's the way i would look at the
reason why we can't just
use the computers we have today and
simulate what's going on in
some complex quantum system just too
hard to do
and the the way that helps us with the
computer is i mean if i think about what
a computer is it has memory it has
processors uh it has algorithms it's
really sort of
the processors that are being improved
here because they can sort of
well let's ask it this way uh there's a
couple of
wrong ways of saying it and let's get
those out of our uh audience's mind
one way that i know scott aronson always
gets annoyed at is that it's not really
like there's a whole bunch of universes
doing separate computations and
eventually finding the right one right i
mean do you agree
with him that that is a bad way of
thinking about quantum computing
it's not completely wrong but it's very
misleading
uh because it would lead you to expect
that we can speed up anything
like quantum computer any problem we
want to solve
um and the catch is what i said earlier
that
you know in the end you're gonna have to
measure something and you can only get a
limited amount of
information out even if uh
you know all these computations uh
in some uh you know fanciful uh
description of what's going on are uh
occurring in parallel a
vast number of computations we we got to
eventually
bring them together and read something
out
and so the art of making a quantum
algorithm that's powerful
is that when you combine them all
together you get something useful
and it's not so obvious the thing that
you'll be able to do that no no no
entanglement is very complicated to
describe classically i just
claimed but does that make it useful
it's not so obvious
so said in another way what's obvious is
that
it requires a lot more information to
specify what's going on in an entangled
quantum state than in a bunch of
classical qubits
but it is not at all obvious that you
can put that to useful work
yeah and i think you know the best
uh reason we have to think that quantum
computers
are powerful is that we can't simulate
them with ordinary classical computers
now
that doesn't tell us exactly what
they're good for but
it does kind of point us in the right
direction you know this was feynman's
idea 40 years ago
uh almost exactly 40 years ago it was in
may of
1981 that he proposed that if you want
to simulate
quantum systems complex quantum systems
with many particles
um on a computer you shouldn't use an
ordinary computer because that'll be
just too hard it should be a quantum
computer
and that's still the best idea we have
about how to
apply quantum computation to something
that people will care about
because simulating quantum systems is
important if we can
you know we if we could we would
simulate
complex materials and complex molecules
on our computers now and predict how
they'll
behave and that would point us
presumably
towards um new types of materials with
properties that
we find useful or new types of
catalysts or pharmaceuticals and so on
and to a certain extent people do that
of course in quantum chemistry and in
computational quantum physics
but it's very limited what we can do
with ordinary computers just because
it's so hard to
simulate highly entangled quantum
systems
and that's what we have if we have many
particles and they're interacting
strongly quantum mechanically with one
another it's really hard to simulate
with a quantum computer we think we'd be
able to do that efficiently
and that's the i from what we can
currently foresee
that's the application which is most
likely
to have a big impact on the world now
quantum
computing is so different from the
information processing we've been
familiar with up to now then
you know we probably have very limited
ability
to forecast what its most important
applications are going to be
but based on what we can currently
project and
have some understanding of it's those
applications to
simulating complex matter many particles
interacting quantum mechanically
which will be the most important
application now it came as a bit of a
shock
and that's what uh you know caught my
attention in 1994
that you could use quantum computers to
speed up solutions to other problems
which don't
on the face of it seem to have anything
to do with quantum computing
and you know shore discovered that
quantum computers would be
very good at breaking codes that they
could do things like finding prime
factors of very large numbers
um and of course that
caused interest in the field to ramp up
sharply because
people care about breaking code some
people do
but in the long run uh you know i don't
think that's likely to be
the uh application that's
going to um be a broad interest and
might affect people's
everyday lives well it will in the short
run i mean it's disruptive
that quantum computers will be able to
break the codes that we use and which we
do use in our everyday lives
you know whenever you're uh going to a
website
that has that little padlock uh you know
next to the url
you're using some some public key crypto
system
and the ones that are in most widespread
use uh today
quantum computers will be able to break
uh those
cryptosystems are based on the
presumption
that although by doing a hard
computation you can break the codes that
those computations are just too hard
so if you wanted to break rsa which is
one of the most widely
used crypto systems now you'd have to be
able to factor
numbers that are 2 000 bits long and
and that's still pretty far out of reach
with the most powerful
uh supercomputers we have now uh with
quantum computers that
um that won't be a hard problem and then
we'll have to protect our privacy a
different way and
what most likely is going to happen is
people will switch
to new public key crypto systems based
on problems
which we don't think quantum computers
can solve efficiently
and uh you know that will uh mean we'll
all have to
change uh you know our
uh browser software or something like
that
but for most people maybe it won't have
such a big impact on
on their everyday lives it's always fun
listening to you talk about this stuff
because you're clearly super excited
about quantum computers but also just
so extremely careful about not over
hyping them that you know that
i can always see the battle going back
and forth between you you know in your
own mind like
saying how interesting it is but you can
see how people who only know a little
bit about it
could get carried away and you want to
protect against that
well there's a lot of the hype it's it's
an issue um
i mean well you know what's happening
in the last few years seems kind of
extraordinary to
to those of us who've been working in
the field for 20-plus years because you
know it started out
well from the start what part of what
was exciting about it for me
is that you know it had an experimental
side and it had a theoretical side
and you might say kind of a big gap
between the two
but people were really trying to do
quantum computing already in the in the
90s
and you know it came along at a at an
opportune time
that when uh this factoring algorithm
was discovered and and people started to
think seriously about what other
applications they would
there would be the experimental
physicists had just
you know in the past decade or so
acquired
the tools to manipulate uh single atoms
and to uh you know manipulate single
electrons and things like that
with a motivation which initially didn't
have much to do with computing
one motivation was we want we wanted
better clocks
and the technology for making really
good atomic
clocks is not that different from the
technology we need to operate a quantum
computer
so you know it was fun that there was
interaction between the theory and the
experiment
but it wasn't like um you know we all
were going to launch startups you know
some of you 18 or 20 years ago now
everybody's launching startups
and uh you know there's a lot of money
sloshing around and they're also big
companies
that are making hefty investments like
like microsoft and
you know ibm and google and intel and
actually uh amazon which i have some
affiliation with now
um and
people are excited and the excitement
to a certain extent is good uh it
optimism uh
propels things forward it creates
opportunities for young people
it the investment uh accelerates
progress
but uh if expectations are
unrealistic you know we'll get burned
eventually
and i think i do expect that quantum
computing
is going to have a big impact on
society well we don't know exactly how
far off that is
right not gonna happen in five years i
don't think some people think it will
happen in five years or ten
i think that's unlikely um
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't be
you know pushing ahead and developing
the technology
and you know there are there are related
technologies which might have
practical impact on a shorter time scale
like
um sensing technologies quantum
sensing has um applications
that uh are developing you know that
better quantum sensors they have
applications to fundamental physics that
you and i might be interested in
but also everybody needs to measure
things more accurately and
with higher resolution and um
you know less invasively that's
important in
materials it's important in medicine
and the technology for quantum sensing
has a lot in common with the technology
for quantum computing
um so i think
you know the excitement to a certain
extent is warranted
but um we um we shouldn't expect
everything to happen at once
it's a sustained investment it's going
to take a lot of effort
to make quantum computing a big thing in
the sense that it
uh you know really benefits humankind
your data is now one of the most
valuable commodities in the world and
protecting your data has never been so
important that's why i like to recommend
nordvpn
a virtual private network that keeps
your
wi-fi safe from intrusion nordvpn is
very easy to use it's one click
and you're using a different server in
another country with over 5000 servers
that get involved
it has amazing speed confirmed by the
speed test nordvpn
is the fastest vpn out there i like it
because when i'm traveling in a cafe
in an airport you can feel secure nor
vpn will protect your data from hackers
and block malware sites from attacking
your computers
and you can have nordvpn on up to six
devices so not only your laptop
but your mobile phone your smart tv and
so on so go to
https nordvpn.com
mindscape that's nordvpn dot
mindscape or use code mindscape to get a
two-year plan
plus a bonus gift with a huge discount
well i mean i get it because we all know
the technology is changing the world and
it's advancing rapidly and
everyone wants to know the next big
thing and when you take computing which
everyone knows is important
and marry it with quantum which everyone
knows is mysterious
it sounds like it could change the world
very dramatically so
i'm sure there's sort of a feedback
mechanism between people who do and do
not understand
quantum computing about getting excited
about the very near-term prospects
well
here's how it looks to me that right now
quantum computers that are at a pretty
interesting stage
what's interesting well we can
you know build systems with 50 to 100
cubits
that's interesting because that's
already large enough
so that it's quite hard just by brute
force
to simulate with our most powerful
classical
computers what the quantum computer is
doing so in that sense
it's natural to start thinking seriously
about
what could the applications be up for
these
near-term quantum devices
what kind of problems can they solve but
they're really noisy
in other words the hardware isn't very
reliable
so you when you do a quantum computation
just like with the classical one you
have to put together
a lot of elementary operations you know
and then in the end you read out a
result
but uh with the best quantum hardware we
have now
in devices that have lots of qubits
when you do the fundamental two qubit in
operations you know the entangling
operations on pairs of qubits you make
an error like once every couple hundred
times
so you can put together a circuit with
you know more than
a thousand or so gates and and read out
a result that's useful and that's a real
limitation
now we uh we understand
that even if the hardware is noisy as
long as it's not
really really noisy there's an idea
called quantum era correction that we
can use to
control the errors but uh that's very
very expensive
in terms of overhead the number of
physical qubits that you need
particularly with the kinds of error
rates we have now or
you know with the physical hardware um
or even if it's a little bit better than
what we have now so i think it's really
really important to make
better hardware uh to have
uh you know operations with error rates
which aren't
uh you know one percent or uh um
half a percent but 10 to the minus five
or something like that now that's really
hard
but that's i'd like to see the focus
there
because that'll take us uh more rapidly
to the regime where quantum computers
can um
can really solve things that we can't
solve classically and including these
applications
to physics and chemistry that at least
uh you know for people in the physical
sciences
are uh are exciting and uh something
we're impatient to
realize if the focus is instead on
you know well can we find something
interesting to do with these kind of
these very limited quantum devices that
that we have now
um well i didn't get that
could you try again that mystery
you see even siri doesn't get it um
yeah then i'm afraid we're you know we
might wind up with nothing
because it's possible well look
it's good to try things you got to
experiment you got this cool thing and
you want to see what it can do
and i think as a physics discovery tool
it's already interesting
you know because we can study the
behavior
of a quantum system that's strongly
interacting and becomes highly entangled
which we can't simulate and
understanding the things they can do
just from a point of view
of understanding physics better that i
there i do see
progress happening in five years right
but as far as a practical application
the customers will want to pay for
because you know they'll be able to uh
improve their financial portfolio or
solve some optimization problem i think
we'll have to be pretty lucky
to see applications like that um that
are really impactful
in say the next five years but that's
where a lot of the focus is
and i will confess because you should be
thinking about the longer term
if we're going to make this into a real
thing then uh
we have to focus on the really hard
problems of advancing the technology
i've said this before out loud on the
podcast uh but but not to you which is
the confession
that one of the many dumb big mistakes
i've made in my physics career was
uh i saw a paper by you i think it was
in the 1990s
about quantum error correction and i
instantly thought to myself like that is
the most boring thing
anybody could be thinking about i mean
obviously important if you want to build
something but it doesn't seem like
the sort of intellectual fun that we all
like to have as theoretical physicists
but
i was utterly wrong right i mean you
know why don't i mean maybe you can let
the audience know a little bit that
there is there really is
uh a fascinating set of ideas associated
with quantum error correction
not just uh an engineering project to
make the computers better
well i'm not i'm not an engineer
i'm a physicist and
even back in the 90s
what i thought was most exciting for me
about quantum computing is that it
gives us a different way of looking at
problems in basic physics including in
condensed matter physics
but also you know in quantum field
theory and
quantum gravity the kind of stuff that
you and i like
um i think quantum era correction
is as important as
contribution to science as the discovery
that uh you know there are fast quantum
algorithms that there are some problems
that we can solve because it's really an
amazing thing
uh we um normally
for good reasons think well quantum
mechanics that's about
little things atoms you know a little
single electrons or whatever and uh and
big things are classical
and uh we think that for good reason
because of the phenomenon we call d
coherence
when you scale a system up um
it's very hard to isolate it from the
outside world yeah
it inevitably interacts with its
environment and those interactions with
the environment sort of cause the
quantum information to leak to the
outside
and it doesn't behave like a quantum
system anymore it behaves like something
we can describe classically
essentially because information about uh
what the system is doing is
is redundantly stored in everything all
around it
and that's not quantum anymore that
becomes classical
and what quantum era correction is about
is that in principle
you know we can scale a system up
many particles doing very complicated
quantum mechanical things
and keep it quantum and we don't do that
by
perfectly isolating it from the
environment
because that's just too hard um but what
we do
is we take the information that the
quantum system
is processing and we make that invisible
to the environment and you know how we
do it with entanglement
we take the information that we want to
protect
and we store it in the form of some very
highly entangled state
shared by many particles and then the
environment comes along and it's kicking
the system
and you know peering into it and and
it's looking at the particles a few at a
time
but because the system is so entangled
it can't see the protected information
when it interacts with just a few
particles at a time
just like that hundred page book i was
talking about you know when you look at
one page
you don't see any of the information
that's in the book the information in
that we've cleverly encoded it in such a
way that when you look at just
you know parts of the system one at a
time you don't see the encoded
information at all
uh therefore it can be robust and we've
also figured out how you can process it
even when it's encoded in that
in that very uh highly entangled form
and uh i mean that's a tremendous
insight that we can make
really complex large quantum things
behave quantumly
despite the effects of decoherence
which uh we have correctly believed
explains why big things are classical
and little things are quant
with an outsmart decoherence that's the
lesson
and and this was controversial for a
while you know back in the mid 90s not
surprisingly you know people started
talking about quantum computing and
you could break codes and all that and
good physicists said that'll never
happen
because they physicists who were very
experienced with
decoherence including in the lab like
sergi roche who
won a nobel prize for figuring out how d
coherence works
and uh you know he said it was uh
the theorist's dream but the
experimentalist nightmare
because you could never really control
the quantum system it's really hard
and you know we're not all the way there
yet but we're making progress and we
understand conceptually
how to scale things up and still make a
complex quantum system work and i think
that's just
an amazing scientific breakthrough
let me see if i can rephrase it just so
i know that i understand what's going on
here um
as you said there's a lot of richness
and complexity
in the quantum system itself but when we
look at it when we measure it
in some sense we only extract a
classical result with some
probability right we the cubic can be up
or down but we see
only one or the other and likewise for
many qubits um
and d coherence in a sense is is making
a measurement of the system right it's
the environment the outside world
becoming entangled and then sort of
ruining the quantumness like you said
and
so the quantum era correction game is
putting the information into the quantum
system in such a way that it is not
being measured away
by the environment is that is that fair
oh you said it much better than i did
you should be a podcaster i should write
books about this yeah
that's exactly what i meant good very
very good and so
yeah then then let's uh make it real i
know that neither one of us is an
engineer but what are your favorite
ways to make qubits and entangle them
what are your favorite physical
manifestations here that we could uh
build into a computer
well so it you mean what what kind of
hardware do i like for yeah
what's your favorite qubit well first of
all um
you know i think it's important and
great that there are a lot of different
hardware
approaches that people are pursuing and
and trying to develop
because we don't have a clear
understanding
of what type of quantum hardware is
going to have the best
long-term prospects for scaling up to
large systems right now the two leading
technologies
are superconducting circuits and
atomic qubits uh usually
uh ions you know electrically charged
qubits which you can trap with
electromagnetic fields
so what do you need if you're going to
have quantum hardware what do you need
well you need qubits
you would like to have a system where
you can scale it up to
many qubits you want them to
have long coherence times as we say in
other words for it to take a long time
for the environment to measure the qubit
and then you want to be able to
manipulate them quickly compared to that
time scale you want to be able to get
them to do something before the
environment
spoils at all and
of course you want to be able to read
them out in the end you want to be able
to measure them accurately
so it's tricky to come up with a system
that meets all um
all of those to zidarata but atoms are
pretty good qubits
you can take an atom um
and you can control it with lasers for
example
and it could be in either its ground
state its lowest energy state or some
excited state you'd like that to be an
excited state that doesn't decay
back to the ground state very quickly
that's how you get the long coherence
time
so you can actually create with a laser
a
a state which is a superposition of the
ground state and the excited state you
can manipulate that that's good
you can read it out pretty easily i mean
you do it with lasers again
you can uh shine a laser with the right
frequency on an atom and if it's in
one state like the ground state
it will absorb the light and readmit it
very rapidly so it glows but if it's in
another state
then the light doesn't see it so it
stays dark so you shine a laser and
some of them shine some of them don't
those are the zeroes and ones
so that all works great as with other uh
quantum computing technologies the
hardest part is you got to get qubits to
interact you have to be able to perform
entangling operations on pairs of qubits
and that's why it's useful for them to
be electrically charged
then they have coulomb interactions you
know the repulsive interactions and
you can leverage that to kind of couple
together
the internal states of the qubits
and their emotional states as they're
vibrating
in um in a trap and that's how you can
get them to interact in a
pretty well-controlled way and do pretty
good entangling two cupid gates
so that's uh that's a good technology
now superconducting circuits is
something really completely different
but it has
it satisfies all the desiderata and now
the um what's being manipulated
is the collective motion of billions of
pairs of electrons
okay it's a circuit for a single dot but
it's very very cold
you know it's at 10 or 20 millikelvin or
something like that
um so it's a material that conducts
electricity
uh without resistance that would that's
what we mean by a superconductor
but you make it much colder than it
needs to be to be a superconductor
because you don't want to have a lot of
uh
stray uh well essentially light except
it's microwave light
at those low temperatures which could be
you know
interacting with the electron motion and
now you can have this isn't this isn't
the way you really do it uh
in practice for practical reasons but
you can imagine
you've got a loop of uh wire
it's conducting electricity without
resistance but it could be going around
either clockwise or counterclockwise
and those are like the two states of
qubit and um
you can those can also be in
superposition you know it can be a
little bit of going
clockwise a little bit of going
counterclockwise
and uh you can read out these
uh circuits uh i mean the key thing is
well actually the way you do it is you
couple it to another thing
um like a um
a microwave resonator just like a thing
that um
a waveguide just a photon waveguide
and the uh you know the frequency of
that
waveguide depends on whether the qubits
in one state or another so you can read
it out
so that's all great too uh now these uh
are about the best technologies we have
and in both cases you can you know build
devices with tens of qubits but again
those entangling two cupid gates have
pretty high error rates you know like at
the one percent level we got to do much
better than that
now i looking forward i do have a
preference for the superconducting
qubits
because there are there's a lot of
um opportunity to sort of fool around
with the electrical engineering of the
uh
superconducting devices well i wouldn't
even put it that way because it's more
fundamental than that you have a lot of
there are a lot of tricks you can play
um and uh
there are you know a few ideas we're
pursuing that might result
in having much much better performance
for the gates and that'll make a huge
difference because it means in the
in the near term we can conduct uh you
know we can execute larger circuits
and still get reasonable signal to noise
when we read up
and in the longer term it means we'll be
able to do error correction with a lower
cost and that'll make it less expensive
to scale things up further
but you know there so there could be big
surprises
and coming from from other technologies
a few years ago
i wouldn't have mentioned uh what is now
one of the most promising approaches we
what we call rydberg atoms
it just means an atom now is either in
its ground state or is really really
highly excited
with some electron and a very you know
uh large orbit and those guys have
a big dipole moment so they can interact
strongly with one another that
you know makes it uh well that way they
have interesting interactions and they
can interact
quickly you can read them out it's it's
got a lot of great features
and and that's really come along rapidly
in just the last couple of years
and there could be other things like
that which sort of take a leap forward
because we're really in early days i
think as far as the technology goes
it's interesting that your favorite is
the superconducting circuits because
when you mention the atoms
there seems to be an obvious advantage
of atoms namely they are small
so we could pack a lot of them close
together but
i mean maybe our ambitions are not to
have
10 to the 10 qubits but only you know
thousands of qubits and so
we don't need to make them that small
but what is the
do you need
yeah and that might be a big thing but
you know it's not so easy with the atoms
either
so if you use this trapped
ion technology uh remember the way you
get the
atoms to interact with one another is
through their
coulomb interactions the way they're
vibrating in the trap
and if you put in more and more ions uh
you get um more and more normal modes of
vibration
and then you're going to try to drive
though they correspond to different
microwave frequencies and
you're driving it with lasers which are
optical but you can have differences
between frequencies of different lasers
you know which can uh
excite different modes but it it gets
uh it gets to be a pretty thick forest
of uh
you know normal modes if you put in too
many ions so
it gets very difficult uh you know once
you have more than uh
i don't know 32 64 ions something like
that okay
and so then you've got to it'll have to
be some kind of modular design
so you'll have a lot of processors maybe
each one
has tens of ions and you've got gotta
get them to talk to one another
uh so you know so they can share
entanglement and so
you need uh some way of
uh designing an interconnect between
traps people have ideas about how to do
that but it's hard
or otherwise you can have a trap with
with lots of zones
where you have a few ions in one zone
and a few ions in another but then you
have to be able to move the ions
between zones so you can transfer
entanglement from one zone to another if
you're going to
get a highly entangled state with many
ions and
you know people are working on that too
uh but it's hard everything's hard yeah
everything's hard
nobody said it would be easy quantum
computing is hard that's why we haven't
made more progress
uh well we made a lot of progress but
it's only uh
you know it's been decades of
improvement
in the design of the qubits and the
control and the fabrication
and and all that but we still have a
long way to go and how do you get the
superconducting loops to
entangle with each other and interact oh
well the superconducting circuits um
you know they have magnetic fields and
electric fields so they can
interact either capacitively that means
the electric field or
inductively that means the magnetic
field
and uh you know of course the the art is
to control those things well
yeah um yeah it should what should i be
visualizing in terms of the geometry are
these arranged
in a line or a a plane or a 3d grid
well 3d is hard but uh there are
two two-dimensional layouts the
uh pretty much the state-of-the-art
still in
um superconducting quantum computers
is this device that um that google built
a couple of years ago now which they
call sycamore
it has 53 working qubits they're in a
two-dimensional array
you can execute entangling operations on
pairs of qubits in that array
uh which are neighbors to one another
and um they
are able to do a sequence of
you know layers of such entangling gates
in an experiment they did in 2019
they did up to 20 layers and
something like um you know a thousand
operations all together
and because of the noise that i keep
talking about then when they measured
all 53 cubits at the end you know they
get the right answer about one time out
of
500 uh not such good signal noise but
then they
they can do they can run it millions of
times in just a few minutes
and uh the same circuit over and over
again and then they get
um you know a good enough sample of of
the output to have something that's
statistically useful
and already that um quantum computation
is something that's really hard to
simulate um 53 cubits is a lot
and you know with the best classical
methods that we have
to simulate what sycamore is doing in
just a few minutes um
on a classical supercomputer takes at
least days
so in that sense although you know i
sometimes i say
uh it's quantum david versus classical
goliath because
the classical computer is this huge
system it
covers two the equivalent of two tennis
courts and it's
burning megawatts of power the sycamore
is just a
chip you know just doing its thing
inside
inside a dilution refrigerator um
and yet in a sense it's doing something
that goliath has a very hard time uh
keeping up with now it's not doing
anything useful
uh it's uh the computation that it's
doing
is uh is useful for only one purpose
to demonstrate that the quantum device
can do something that's really hard for
a classical device to do
oh you you mentioned that it's in a
dilution refrigerator
even though it's tiny i mean do we
imagine that there will ever be a day
when we will have iphones with quantum
computers inside
well they if we if we're carrying them
in our pockets they probably won't be at
20
millikay you know uh but uh
it could be a different technology there
are there are quantum technologies that
work
at at room temperature okay um
and uh you know um
why would you want to have it in your
iphone that's another question
it you know you might want to have it as
uh
sort of a smart card um yeah you know we
haven't talked about quantum
cryptography
but which is uh another uh
intellectually interesting idea where
exactly what the best use case is still
a little bit murky
but the great thing about quantum
information from the point of view
of security is that
you can't eavesdrop on
quantum systems without disturbing them
in some
detectable way um you know this is
what's really different
or one of the things that's really
different we talked about entanglement
but
um one thing that's really different
about quantum information from classical
information
is you can look at classical information
or you can copy it
and you don't have to change it but if
it's quantum information and you observe
it
you disturb it it's gone yeah and
that's actually uh can be the basis of
a kind of cryptographic scheme where
you're sending quantum states
and if somebody tries to eavesdrop you
can do a test to see
that the state has been disturbed and uh
you can base security then not on some
assumption about
the computation you would need to break
the protocol is too hard to do in any
reasonable amount of time it's really
based on the laws of physics
that you can't collect information
without creating a disturbance
so maybe you'll want to have a little
quantum i don't know a smart card that
you can carry around so when you go to
the atm i don't know if people will be
going to the atm by then
but wherever you go you can have someone
uh verify your card but nobody would be
able to copy it
you know i i i have no idea what good a
quantum iphone would be a quantum
computer inside the iphone or smartphone
would be but i am 99.99 sure that it
would be incredibly useful just because
even i'm old enough that you know i
remember a day when people said why
would you ever need more than 64k of ram
in your personal computer i don't see
what the usefulness of that would be and
then i remember when people said
why do we need web browsers you know we
we have uh the phone book and you know
we have other ways to to do things and
so even if i can't foresee what the
applications are going to be
there are different kinds of things as
you've been saying that you can do with
uh
quantum algorithms and computers and so
someone will come up with ways to put
them to use this is my conviction well
you remember when nobody could imagine
why anyone would want a computer at home
yeah that usually the explanation was
what you can organize your recipes
yeah my explanation why i need a web
browser at the time was well i can order
a pizza
on a web page and people said well we
have ways we have ways of doing that
other ways but okay um
let's get more into what exactly we can
do with the quantum computers i mean one
thing that slipped by there which
because i know some people are not uh
completely convinced of it or haven't
heard of yet
we have quantum computers they are
working right i mean
there's the ibm quantum experience where
you can go onto a web page and run a
little quantum algorithm yourself so
it's not like
the existence of the computers is the
issue it's all these scalings and error
correction and decoherence is the issue
yeah
there are quantum computers you can you
can use them
and there are several different uh
hardware
providers you know where you can have
cloud access actually aws
has the system they call bracket where
you know you can
access an ion trap quantum computer and
a superconducting quantum computer and
um but they're not useful yet
sure you're not able to solve problems
we can't
solve other ways now that doesn't mean
people it doesn't make sense for people
to be playing around with them
it probably does make sense um
because they are going to be useful and
uh if you're you know if you have a
company that and for which
uh solving hard computational problems
is
of value then you know you might want to
have some quantum expertise on board
have some people who are familiar with
what quantum computers can potentially
do
and can explore the potential
applications
uh you know to the problems they're
interested in um
but how long it will be before
quantum computers can solve
problems that people really care about
say for business reasons um
and solve them with a speed up relative
to what
the best classical computers running the
best algorithms for solving
uh the same problems how long is that
that's going to be i don't think anybody
really knows that
that sounds pretty there's a lot of
interest in optimization just because
everybody wants to optimize things
and there are heuristic ideas about how
you can use a quantum computer to skip
up sorry to speed up optimization
but we don't really have very convincing
theoretical arguments
that quantum computers will give big
speed ups for optimization they might
um we know we know there is they we know
they can speed up exhaustive search
uh but that's not a spectacular speed up
you know
if you're looking for uh you know the
solution to
the traveling salesman problem or
something like that you know you want to
find a route
that visits a whole bunch of cities
which is as short as possible
uh you could always solve that problem
by trying all the routes
and finding one that's shortest but uh
you know that's completely inefficient
nobody can solve the problem that way
for more than
you know a few cities um
and uh exhaustive search isn't a good
way to solve it but quantum computing
can
uh speed up exhaustive search but it
doesn't speed it up
by a spectacular amount the way it
speeds up factoring
the time as that's assuming you had
quantum hardware with
you know the same clock speed the same
number of operations
per second as your classical computer
yeah how you can solve the problem in
the square root
of the time it would take to solve it um
classically
that's something but it's probably going
to be a long time
before uh you know quantum computers are
of high enough quality
for us to be able to take advantage of
that speed up so i think
uh the the speed ups that are going to
have an impact
first will be the ones where we think it
really is uh
exponential speed up a spectacular speed
up um
solving those problems in material
science and chemistry
um is an example but
those require lots of qubits and you
know
that's probably going to be a while now
just because we theorists can't
guarantee
that quantum computers are going to
speed up certain problems
doesn't mean um you know that it's not
going to happen
it's important to experiment classically
we have lots of examples
where there are heuristic algorithms
which turn out
to have a lot of practical value even
though the theorists can't very well
explain why they're so valuable machine
learning is the most
obvious example now you know
ai is having a big impact you can drive
autonomous vehicles you can win it go
you can recognize spaces
using uh deep learning networks and
we have very limited theoretical
understanding of why for
those applications we can we can train
those networks efficiently
people just tried it and found out that
it worked right so if you're an optimist
you can say well let's you know try a
lot of things
on these near-term quantum devices and
see if something works
and that's a that's a worthwhile thing
to do and
that's one way in which these devices
that are now available on the cloud will
be used and are being used
um but you know in the near term you
could say maybe the most important
application
for these uh quantum computers we have
now
is they can help us learn to make bigger
quantum computers
and you know this quantum era correction
idea i keep harping on
uh we can we've gotten to the point now
where we can start to try out quantum
error correction on the devices we have
now
and try to improve it and get it to run
more efficiently
and lower overhead costs come up with
new ideas
uh we have to see whether the noise in
the devices we can really build
has the right properties for quantum
error correction to
work effectively and that's i mean
that's interesting scientifically and i
think also interesting
from the point of view of moving the
technology
to the next level so that's another
thing we should be doing with these
computers that we have now
i mean maybe we could be a little bit
more specific about what our theoretical
knowledge is about the amount of quantum
speed up we can either
expect or hope for so my understanding
is
there definitely is speed up in certain
well understood cases
uh this exponential speed up the speed
up that we would really
like to see what's the status there is
it
that we it's possible that every problem
can be exponentially sped up or do we
know there are any problems that could
be exponentially sped up what do we
think about that
well i guess it depends partly on what
your your standard for rigor is
it's pretty low i would say we have uh
we have pretty convincing arguments
that quantum computers will not be able
to efficiently solve
exactly the
um np hard problems you know the
hard instances of the so-called np-hard
problems
and np means the problems where when we
find a solution we can efficiently
verify that the solution is
correct um the traveling salesman
problem that i
mentioned is an example of a so-called
np-hard problem that means
it's an mp once you you know find the
route you can
check that the route has a total mileage
less than some specified number
um it's hard
to find the route and that problem um
has the property that if you can solve
that efficiently then you can solve
a ton of other optimization problems
efficiently and that would
be of great interest for many
applications we don't think quantum
computers can
find exact solutions to
those problems um efficiently now
they may be able to find approximate
solutions
um with some advantage over
uh classical computers we don't know
that for sure that's really more of a
speculation
but that's you know something we should
uh
continue to strive for and try to
clarify
and that's part of what is motivating
the effort to use these near-term
quantum devices
to um see if we can speed up
optimization
um but uh
well i mentioned factoring a couple of
times so what's the deal with factoring
the truth is we can't prove that
factoring is hard classically
it's not one of these np-hard problems
um it's pretty hard but not that hard
well we thought no it we why do we think
it's hard because
really really smart people have tried
very very hard
right to come up with a better factoring
algorithm and they've been doing it for
decades and they haven't succeeded
and you know but some
some brilliant student may come along
tomorrow and come up with factoring
algorithm that's possible
but we do know theoretically you know if
we have a quantum computer that
operates reliably it will be able to
solve factoring
efficiently so that's it's not exactly
exponential it's
super polynomial it's almost exponential
to speed up it's a very spectacular
speed up
you can solve factoring problems if you
have a quantum computer with a
you know clock speed uh that seems
physically
uh reasonable you know you can solve it
in uh
in hours and even if it would take the
age of the universe to solve it with the
best classical computer so that's a real
speed up
and that's the kind of thing that uh
gets our our pulses uh quickening
now as far as these um applications to
uh material science and chemistry and
and so on again i would say
the best argument we have
that those problems are really hard
classically as nobody can figure out how
to solve them
again it's not for lack of trying
physicists and chemists have been trying
for decades to come up with
better algorithms they can run on
classical computers
for simulating the behavior of quantum
systems with many particles but still
the best algorithms that we have
have a runtime which rises exponentially
with the number of qubits
quantum computers will be able to solve
those problems efficiently
problems like simulating the dynamics of
a quantum system you know that's
evolving
with time um and uh
well with some caveats uh they'd be able
to
solve problems like finding um
the low energy states uh you know
finding the ground state of a molecule
and things like that
so we're thinking of things like
chemistry materials superconductivity
stuff like that
yeah so those are the applications where
i feel pretty confident
the problems really are classically hard
and quantum computers will uh be able to
solve them efficiently
but you know efficiently is um
computer scientists mean something
technical by that of
you know by that those words they mean
that the
time it takes to solve the problem
scales in a reasonable way with the size
of the problem like you know the number
of uh
particles in the material or the number
of
electrons in the molecule or something
like that
that doesn't necessarily mean it's
really practical
um you know and uh so
we're um we're gonna have to scale up
quantum computers
um quite a bit from where they
are now before we can do simulations of
materials
that uh are too hard to do with our
classical computers that might teach us
something interesting
i mean one of the holy grails in
uh computational quantum materials
for uh decades has been trying to
understand high temperature
superconductors better
and you know try to point us in the
direction of discovering
new high-temperature superconductors uh
potentially of great practical interest
um if we can get them to room
temperature in particular
um and uh that's a really hard
computational problem
um and uh
already you know you can consider model
systems with a number of particles you
know which is
of order 100 or so where that's too hard
to solve with a
classical computer you should be able to
solve
the quantum computer but then
the real cost of running that quantum
computation
comes back to this issue that the
quantum computers aren't perfect
and we'll probably have to use quantum
error correction
to run those algorithms and
how many physical qubits we need then is
going to depend
on how reliable the hardware is you know
what the error rates are
and right now the error rates are pretty
bad so it would probably mean millions
of physical cubits
and what do we have now maybe 100
physical cubits not quite that
so it's a big big gap to cross from
where we are now
to uh where we'll be confident
quantum computers can solve problems
that uh
material scientists are interested in
which seem to be too hard to solve
classically i hope it'll happen soon
and these people mention i mean these
kinds of problems are
it's easy to see why they're a natural
fit for quantum computers because you're
using entangled qubits to simulate
literally entangled materials does that
mean that we shouldn't necessarily
hold out any hope for quantum computers
being especially good
for simulating other complex but
classical systems like economies or
societies or technologies or anything
like that
well i wouldn't put it as strongly as uh
we shouldn't hold out hope
but i would say i don't see any
very persuasive argument that quantum
computers will be good at problems like
that
good um yeah i think
as best we currently understand like i
said we don't
expect quantum computers to dramatically
speed up everything um
and so the class of problems for which
uh
you know very substantial speedups are
possible
is something um it's probably limited
and exactly what are those problems what
are the things that are too hard to
solve classically that we can solve
quantumly
i don't think we really know so much
about that yet you know
our understanding of it has advanced
some over the last 25 years or so but
still like i said the best idea we have
i keep coming back to it is simulating
quantum systems with quantum computers
um that uh they have these applications
to cryptology came as kind of a surprise
and um there could well be other
surprises
uh that probably will be and for the
young people in the audience just
so they know i mean there's no proof
that there isn't
a genius algorithm that uses quantum
entanglement to help us solve these big
simulation problems right
well it's really really hard from to
show from first
principles yeah that a problem is hard
right in fact
i really can't we're very bad at that
the uh so much i mean there's a whole
field
of complexity theory the study of
hardness of problems which has many
beautiful results
um but uh it's largely founded on
unproven conjectures
right the most fundamental and famous of
which
is the uh peanut equals np conjecture
you know that they're
i alluded to it in passing before that
there are problems
for which we can verify the solution
easily once we find the solution but
it's really hard to find the solution
you know we don't know for sure that you
can't solve the traveling salesman
problem lickety-split if you find the
right algorithm but
uh most people who've thought seriously
about it think that's really a hard
problem
now on the other hand quantum computers
can't solve that efficiently either
so we really have to uh
you know um it's it's quite it's quite
subtle
to find this uh sweet spot
where an important part of the topic is
understanding what's hard classically
but to find these problems that uh
you know we can solve efficiently
quantumly and we can't
solve efficiently classically theorists
have made only limited progress on that
and
you know once we have the quantum
computers i'm sure we'll learn a lot
more
just by experimenting with let's let's
bring it home maybe by going back to
uh field theory and quantum gravity and
black holes that you were thinking about
before you made
this phase transition and it turns out
that you're still there like you have
not completely
abandoned this right uh these ideas from
quantum information theory and quantum
computing
turn out to be relevant for
things like the black hole information
problem is that right
yeah and i in a way i sort of came back
to it
um
that's i would say they're two big
surprises for me you know
um from the perspective of
the way i thought about the field when i
got started like 25 years ago i actually
believed
early on that um
quantum information was going to be
important for
fundamental questions and physics and it
has had an impact on
you know understanding uh phase
transitions and
quantum matter uh and i thought it would
be helpful for understanding
black holes and quantum gravity as well
which like i said earlier is kind of how
i got into it i
thought i should study quantum
information because that'll help me to
understand
how black holes behave but um
i there was kind of a transition
that i didn't expect from the people who
do quantum gravity for a living
you know very many brilliant people who
are friends of both of us
were not too interested in quantum
information and then suddenly they were
yeah
you know and suddenly you could go to a
uh
a quantum gravity meeting and
the talks would be about quantum era
correction
and computational complexity and
entanglement
and um and that i i found that quite
exciting
and um you know our current perspective
is that space itself
or space time is not truly fundamental
it's sort of an emergent property from
something deeper
and what is the deeper thing well when i
talk about space i mean
geometry you know um what
when one thing is close to another thing
that's a property of geometry
uh where things are relative to one
another that's geometry
and the underlying explanation for
geometry we increasingly believe is
quantum entanglement
you know so uh you and i as it happens
we're on zoom so we're not in the same
room
but you know if we were um
we we could imagine trying to
break the entanglement we don't have to
be in the same room to imagine this
uh try to break the entanglement between
um
you know where i am in space and where
you are
in space and we think that if you did
that you would actually
break space yeah that we would be
disconnected from one another and there
wouldn't be any way to travel from where
you are to where i am
if there weren't for that entanglement
so in that sense
quantum entanglement seems to be what's
gluing space together
and just to be super clear because i
always get people uh um
confused by this it's not the
entanglement between you and me
that gives us the distance it's the
entanglement between invisible
degrees of freedom in the space between
us which is a little bit hard to
visualize
well part of the problem is we don't
understand it as deeply as we would like
to
but we have lots of hints that that's
what's going on
and these ideas which
emerge largely through the study of
quantum computing
like quantum error correction turn out
to be
um to be just what we need to understand
this at a deeper level
kind of makes sense that if space is
going to be an emergent property it
better be pretty robust
so you shouldn't be able to tickle it
and make it fall apart
and it's kind of a quantum era
correcting code that has this property
that you know it's not so so easy
to uh you know break space up
um once you have quantum air correction
uh it becomes harder for the environment
to uh
you know attack a quantum computer and
make it fail
i'm literally trying to understand this
exact feature
of immersion space time better myself
right now for research
writing papers purposes uh so we're at
the end of the podcast
while i have you here i mean can we be a
little bit more specific
can you be about i mean you say
robustness of space that makes perfect
sense but
what is the relationship in an
explicitly as we can be
between a quantum error correcting code
which seems like something you build
into a computer
and the nature of space itself
well here's something that's fairly
concrete um but it requires a bit of a
detour
uh if you're up for that holographic
duality
um and uh so
there's a particular setting in which we
understand quantum gravity
best at present and it gives us a
handle a tool for understanding
properties of black holes that form and
evaporate
and so on and it is a
duality between a
ordinary quantum theory that doesn't
involve gravity at all
but which actually is an alternative way
of describing
gravity in which black holes form and
things
fall and so on so there's a complicated
dictionary
that relates those two descriptions it's
one which is just ordinary quantum
mechanics and the other one that
involves gravity and that dictionary is
actually
the encoding map of a quantum error
correcting code so what does that mean
for example
and we can think of the dictionary in
the following way
that um there's some geometry you know
it's dynamical
black holes are forming and they're
moving around and gravitationally
attracting one another and so on
but this um alternative description that
doesn't involve gravity
lives at the boundary of
this space time and now
you could there's all this wonderful
stuff happening inside
and now you can start messing around
with the boundary there's some map that
takes the physics on the boundary
and maps it to the uh the physics uh
deep inside the space time and now you
state like you start
removing little pieces of the geometry
or uh hitting them with a hammer
or sorry removing little pieces of the
boundary or the boundary right like take
away some of the qubits from the
boundary or
flip them or do something awful to them
but not too many of them
and uh but what's happening deep in the
space time
is is still okay and that's because this
map from the boundary
to what we call the bulk you know where
the interesting gravity is
um it it's very non-local so
things that look local in the ball like
a black hole you know right here in my
room
uh on the boundary that actually
involves lots of degrees of freedom
you know which are entangled with one
another and you can take away
some of those degrees of freedom but you
don't spoil
that entanglement for the most part and
the uh
what's going on with the black hole
doesn't doesn't get altered
so that's an example of what i mean by
quantum error correction
it's a great example and i i think that
um
i i'm tempted to ask so i'll just i'll
just ask it why not um
in that explanation you just gave which
is beautifully clear the role of
holography is absolutely central and you
know in this sense we did by the way
have neda engelhardt on the podcast for
those who want uh
a longer disquisition about that um and
lenny huskin before
before her um
that does live in this context of what
we call the adscft correspondence right
where we have a space time where there
is a boundary that we can identify and
it's a spacetime itself etc etc
and as you know as well as i do our
world does not appear to be
anti-sitter space does that mean that
uh is the holography sort of
a way to answer the questions in a very
simple context but we're gonna have to
do more work to apply it to the real
world or is there a more direct
connection there
it's a toy model it's not the real thing
just as you said it's not our universe
it's something that's easier to
understand than our than our universe
so we understand it better yeah um and
uh
eventually we need to throw away that
crutch uh
and uh well i don't know if you said
these words but uh what i was describing
applies
in what we call anti-dissider space it's
negatively
curved uh space and uh that doesn't seem
to be the one we're living in
um it turns out that it's it's easier to
understand because of this nice
relationship between the quantum system
living on the boundary and uh you know
the the physics going on in the bulk
and i just sit her space um i think the
lessons
are broader that uh the connection
between entanglement and quantum error
correction
and geometry will extend
uh beyond that toy example but um we've
got a lot of work to do
to elicit that now you had netta um
on your uh on your podcast and she told
you about some of these spectacular
recent developments that she's been
involved in
which actually teaches things about the
case
um that's more like the real world
understanding how black holes evaporate
and what happens to the information
in them and the what
she and her collaborators found um i
think also
has a width of quantum error correction
because they uh um
said things like what's going on outside
the black hole is related to what's
going on inside the black hole
and um i think that actually involves
one of these
kind of quantum error correcting maps as
well but we
we need to um we need to flesh that out
sounds like it's a pretty exciting time
when we can bounce back and forth
between um
black holes evaporating and the nature
of space-time and
little circuits super conducting that
will help us solve the traveling
salesman problem
i'm having a blast yeah and so are you i
am and i hope that everyone listening is
also and they
catch some of the spirit that is very
much alive here so john prescott
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast it was a pleasure sean
[Music]
you